if you think much about physics and
cognition and intelligence it's pretty
obvious the human mind is not the
smartest possible general intelligence
any more than humans are the highest
jumpers are the fastest runners we're
not going to be the smartest thinkers if
you are going to work toward AGI rather
than focusing on some narrow application
there's a number of different approaches
that you might take and I've spent some
time just surveying the AGI field as a
whole and organizing an annual
conference on the AGI and then I've
spent a bunch more time on a specific
AGI approach which is based on the open
cog open source software platform in the
big picture one way to approach AGI is
to try to emulate the human brain at
some level of precision and this is the
approach I see for example google
deepmind's taking they've taken deep
neural networks which in their common
form are mostly a model of visual and
auditory processing in the human brain
and now in their recent work such as the
DNC differential neural computer they're
taking these deep networks that model
visual or auditory processing and
they're coupling that with a memory
matrix which models some aspect of what
the hippocampus does which is the part
of the brain that deals with working
memory short-term memory among other
things so this illustrates an approach
where you take neural networks emulating
different parts of the brain and maybe
you take more and more in the neural
networks emulating different parts of
the human brain you try to get them to
all work together not necessarily doing
computational neuroscience but trying to
emulate the way different parts of the
brain are doing processing in the way
they're talking to each other a totally
different approach is being taken by a
guy named Marcus hooter in Australian
National University he wrote a beautiful
book on universal AI in which he showed
how to write a superhuman infinitely
intelligence think
machine and like 50 lines of code the
problem is it would take more computing
power than there is in the entire
universe to run so it's so it's not
practically useful but they're done
trying to scale down from this
theoretical AGI to find something that
that will really work now the approach
we're taking in the OpenCog project is
different than either of those we're
attempting to emulate at a very high
level the way the human mind seems to
work as an embodied social generally
intelligent agent which is coming to
grips with hard problems in the context
of coming to grips with itself and it's
an its life in the world we're not
trying to model the way the brain works
at the level of neurons or neural
networks we're looking at the human mind
more from a high-level cognitive point
of view what kinds of memory are there
well there's semantic memory about
abstract knowledge or concrete facts
there's episodic memory of our
autobiographical history they're sensory
motor memory
there's associative memory of things
that have been related to us in our
lives
there's procedural memory of how to do
things and we then look at the different
kinds of learning and reasoning the
human mind can do we can do logical
deduction sometimes we're not always
good at it we we make emotional
intuitive leaps and strange creative
combinations of things we learn by trial
and error and habit we learn socially by
imitating mirroring emulating or
opposing others these different kinds of
memory and learning that the human mind
has one can attempt to achieve each of
those with a cutting-edge computer
science algorithm rather than trying to
achieve each of those functions and
structures in the way the brain does so
what we have in OpenCog we have a
central knowledge repository which is
very dynamic and lives in RAM on a large
network of computers which we call the
atoms
and for for the mathematicians or
computer science in the audience the the
item space is what you'd call a a
weighted labeled hypergraph so it has
nodes it has links a link can go between
two nodes or a link you go between three
four five or fifty nodes different nodes
and links have different types and the
nodes and links can have numbers
attached to them another link could have
a weight indicating a probability or a
confidence it could have a weight
indicating how important it is to the
system right now or how important it is
in the long term so it should be kept
around in the system's memory on this
atom space this weighted labeled hyper
graph we can have a lot of different AI
processes working together cooperatively
so the the atom space the memory store
is what we would call neural symbolic
that means we can represent nodes and
links that are like neurons in the brain
which is fairly low-level but we can
also represent nodes and links that are
higher-level
representing pieces of symbolic logic
expressions so we can do explicit
logical reasoning which is pretty
abstract and low-level neural net stuff
in the same hyper graph the same atom
space acting on this atom space we have
deep neural networks for visual and
auditory perception we have a
probabilistic logic engine which does
abstract reasoning we have an
evolutionary learning algorithm that
uses genetic algorithm type methods to
try to evolve radical new ideas and
concepts and look for data patterns and
we have a neural net type dynamic that
spreads activity and importance
throughout the network a few other
algorithms a pattern mining algorithm
that just scans through the whole atom
space looking for surprising stuff and
the trick is all these different
cognitive algorithms have to work
together cooperatively
to help each other rather than hurt each
other see the bottleneck in essentially
every AI approach ever taken be it a
neural net a logic engine the genetic
algorithm whatever the bottleneck in
every AI approach ever taken has been
what we call combinatorial explosion and
what that means is you have a lot of
data items your a lot of perceptions
coming into your eye or you have a lot
of possible moves on the chessboard or a
lot of possible ways to move the wheel
of the car and there's so many
combinations of possible data items and
possible things you could do sifting
through all those combinations becomes
an exponential problem I mean if you
have a thousand things there's two to
the one thousandth will hit combine them
and that and that's way too many so how
to sift through combinatorial explosions
is the core problem everyone has to deal
with in a deep neural network as
currently pursued it's solved by making
the network have a very specific
structure which reflects the structure
of visual and auditory streams and in a
logic engine you don't have that sort of
luxury because the logic engine has to
deal with anything not not just sensory
data but what we do in OpenCog is we've
worked out a system where each of the
cognitive processes can help the other
one out when they when it gets stuck in
some combinatorial explosion problems so
if a deep neural network trying to
perceive things gets confused because
it's dark or it's looking at something
it never saw before well maybe the
reasoning engine can come in and do some
inference to cut through that confusion
if najuk already is getting confused and
doesn't know what step to take next
because there's just so many
possibilities out there and not much
information about them well maybe you
fish into your sensory motor memory and
you use deep learning to visualize
something you saw before and that gives
you a clue of how to pair through the
many possibilities that the logic engine
is seeing now you you can model this
kind of cognitive synergy
mathematically using a branch of
mathematics called category theory which
is something I've been working on lately
but what's really interesting more so is
to build a system that manifests this
and achieves general intelligence as a
result and that's what we're doing in
the OpenCog project we're not there yet
to general intelligence but we're
getting there step by step we're using
our open source open cog platform to
control david Henson's beautiful
incredibly realistic humanoid robots
like this Sofia robot which has gotten a
lot of media attention in the last year
we're using OpenCog to analyze
biological data related to the genetics
of longevity and we're doing a host of
other consulting projects using this so
we're we're proceeding on an R&D track
and an application track at the same
time but our end goal with the system is
to use cognitive synergy on our neural
symbolic knowledge store to achieve
initially human level III but that's
just an early stage goal and then AI at
much beyond the human level and that is
another advantage of taking an approach
that doesn't adhere slavishly to the
human brain the brain is pretty good at
recognizing faces because millions of
years of evolution went into that part
of the brain but for doing science or
math or logical reasoning or strategic
planning we're pretty bad and and these
are things that we've started doing only
recently in evolutionary time as a
result of modern culture so I think
actually OpenCog and other AI systems
have potential to be far better than
human beings that the sort of logical
and strategic side of things and I think
that's quite important because if you
take a human being and upgrade them to
like 10,000 IQ the the outcomes might
not be what you want because you you've
got a motivational system and an
emotional system that
basically evolved in pre-human animals
whereas if you architect a system where
rationality and empathy play a deeper
role in the architecture then as its
intelligence routes way up we may find a
more beneficial outcome
[Music]